stop the presses gang got a special
announcement the middle class famous
tour is in full effect hey your tickets
me the bald one the long hair we're
coming to a city near you bring the
squad out it's a great way to introduce
people to the show you get to see some
stand-up you get to play a little ayg
with me in the gipperino it's a good
time hit me out yeah guys we're going to
be in atlanta tampa orlando pittsburgh
buffalo detroit denver phoenix salt lake
city chicago rose man guys it's a great
time can't wait to see you out there get
your tickies now yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is r u garbage it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they grow up to be classy yeah or if
they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
antony's basement she's upstairs having
a nice heart-healthy lunch okay of a
bowl of oatmeal and a gin and tonic nice
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me unamused this week he is the
ceo of ru garbage he's my best pal in
the whole wide world and i love him and
i don't care who knows it
give it up for kj kevin james ryan ah
thanks i love you too buddy
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are true
and then obviously i'm contractually
obligated to mention uh the greatest
website of all time patreon.com are you
garbage you can sign up you get bonus
episodes of ayg hard feelings live
streams the whole nine yards do it is
that sam yam and jack hunty's operation
that is that's their outfit they're good
kids they're good kids and having a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good we love them you love them
give it up for t-bone mcscruffins it's
tobey mcmullen everybody what's up dudes
hey t-bone just see but you guys realize
you're a redhead
debatable god strawberry blonde some
might say
toby cam coming soon by the way
they're chattering in the streets they
want to see you big man a couple more ad
sales get the toby cam going
that's patreon.com folks but gang we
could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest here with us
today for the first time she is a very
funny very successful stand-up comedian
and podcaster she was a regular on kill
tony she's appeared on the joe rogan
experience she tours all over the
country and she is the host of the
resting [ __ ] podcast but the big
question about his mind today is she
garbage i do see a barbed wire with that
too i'm not gonna lie
damn it
that long hair ain't gonna hide that
rednecker i'll tell you that right now
give it up for allie makowski everybody
yeah thank you thanks for coming great
last name too you think so markowski
it's either strong
1950s la private eye
okay
or not
yeah yeah mikotsky or a postmodern
artist oh it's a makovsky it's her new
work it's a makovsky oh that's scary
that's a new makovsky i heard it's good
stuff why you didn't like your last name
growing up
no i i i don't believe in marriage but i
do believe in changing my last name
for any reason
but it's so annoying my boyfriend who
i'm dating i don't want to brag but yeah
i locked one in uh his last name is so
similar to mine that i'm like i'm gonna
have to dump you at some point what is
it can you tell us it's mcdonald's
that's a step down from a coffee totally
i don't know i like a mcdonald's
[Laughter]
it's hard to find the good wendy's where
they do it right that's true they're
really strong they're not all created
equally no they're not i had a popeyes
last night that felt like they they got
angry while making my sandwich and just
crumpled it and then we're like here you
go
it made me upset yeah it's the worst uh
there's a couple of places that do it
right you find a nice a nice wendy's out
in the burbs they treat you right now
yeah yeah where it's the living's a
little slower yeah ones in the inner
city are tough to come by yeah it's not
good little champagne something nice
um what is the origin story of ali
makovsky uh the origin story i grew up
in long beach california okay both of my
parents are longshoremen so they work
they work at the ports of long beach
wow yeah
yeah you're joking no i'm 100 people
your mother's a shoulder my mother got
my dad into being a longshoreman my dad
was like a traveling salesman aka a
cheater okay let's wrap this up
what exactly
is a longshoreman a picture with hooks
all i know is it's guys that rocky used
to shake down for money have you seen
the wire
yes i get i've never seen it but i guess
it's just like that but without like all
the drugs yeah so a longshoreman someone
who works at the ports and like when
those like big [ __ ] carriers come in
and stuff i mean it used to be like you
had to like unload it all i mean like
your mom just have like a chest tattoo
of like an anchor and like a cigar
my dad literally smokes cigars on the
job and whenever i tell people
a lot of people have this idea of me i
think it might be the way i talk or kind
of like 100 you just blew me away yeah i
know i have like a very apathetic
attitude and so people think that i like
come from money or something 100 i
totally thought i thought i thought your
dad's a lawyer your mom's a professor at
vassar or something like that no and
they're just like very blue collar
it's tough when you have a mom who's
your mom's long shoreman longshore woman
all right
charlotte
long beach arm wrestling champ holy [ __ ]
yeah god that's crazy yeah a podcast
over wow
yeah long shoreman yeah so they're both
longshoremen um still active still
activation really still out there
yeah union union
those are only unions yeah yeah so i
like it's good benefits though it's a
great benefit that's why that's they
never leave no i growing up i felt like
i was rich because i got to go to the
doctor i got to have like
like surgeries just for fun sure of
course
we had i had union benefits too growing
up and i remember our co-pay was like
five bucks and other people's was like
50. and i remember looking at him in the
girl i'm like what do your parents do
for a living you gotta shut off 50 bucks
for a nap for an inhaler so they ain't
working the docks i can tell you that i
know i just lost my parents health
insurance and i feel like it's rock
bottom i feel like i'm strong i'm like
what do i do i want to marry a long
shoreman just for the benefits i'm like
mom dad like hook me up with one of your
disgusting friends do you have brothers
and sisters i have two older sisters two
older sisters yeah and i think why
people also think that i like come from
you know maybe an affluent family is
because my sisters are the most basic
beautiful women they just you know they
look like they have stocks in starbucks
like they just what do they do rodeo
what are they what are they no they both
my oldest sister she was working at hulu
for a while and she just stopped doing
that okay yeah but she wasn't like you
know she was like a liaison between the
talent and the company so solid job
she's always like tried to work in
entertainment but now she married a dude
who's wealthy so she's that's it that's
it she said i am yeah and then my other
sister she works for like an online like
pop sugar i think like one of those
online websites okay so she does like
brand deals for them did your parents go
to college no they didn't go to college
i think long beach i think like uh sushi
burritos and surfboards and stuff like
that mm-hmm no
long beach is like a big little city
it's like it's got a lot of diversity
there's a lot of you're on the water
you're near the water
near the water you're not directly long
beach is very big so parts of it are
right on the water we grew up i was like
maybe 15 minutes away from the water and
what did you grow up in a regular house
apartment uh so when my parents were
together we lived in a really cute home
like a nice little three-bedroom house
right by long beach state university
okay and then when they got divorced my
dad lived in a really sketchy apartment
yeah they all my dad did the same thing
they always go to a sketchy place oh
yeah my dad is such a perverted creep i
don't i don't want to share this story
but i feel like this is a good story to
share lay it on us
that's why we're here first of all his
name's larry so like we're starting at
you know zero larry the longshoreman
larry the longshoreman yeah and he was a
children's book we lived in this giant
apartment building and there was you
know a bunch of apartments near us and
my dad had binoculars in the building
and he would try and find women in the
other world that's why you're in there
oh yeah i was like seven years old look
at the hits on her totally my dad's like
classic like old school perv type dude
really yeah and you lived with him and i
lived with him yeah so
full time or split the time split but
primarily with my dad really yeah why is
that because my mom is an alcoholic nice
yeah
okay my parents met oh this is a good
story my parents met at a 12-step
convention in palm desert
it was like a narcotics anonymous or
cocaine anonymous convention
[Laughter]
there should be
um so that's where they met that's where
their love story begins
so they were partiers yeah i mean my mom
i think was just like straight up
alcoholic she wasn't into like drugs or
anything but my dad was a part of her my
dad does come from a somewhat wealthier
family okay like my grandparents they
grew up in like brooklyn like living in
the projects and then made their money i
think in like a liquor store business or
maybe like a wicker furniture business
in brooklyn no they're two completely
separate things and they rhyme she's
like i heard this once it's wicker
liquor yeah
it's either a cupcake shop or uh
racketeering i can't remember which one
i think they did both i think they
started with one and then ended with the
other or whatever but that's they made
their money rags to riches and then it's
so annoying because one of my dad's
siblings is like they have a house in
malibu
they're doing well yeah so growing up
i'm like dad what the [ __ ] happened to
you like this was our this could have
been it could have been us yeah why do
you start longshoremen
you know
yeah needed money pennies yeah it is a
solid living they still work together
sometimes they get like the same job so
they'll be at the same port or whatever
but yeah they still both do they get
along they do they get along they've
gone through you know their phases of
like hating each other or whatever but
now they get along damn and where was
your mom while you were living with your
dad she was also in long beach so she
moved to an apartment that was by the
beach but you had a house i always had a
home yeah no but you an actual started
in a house yeah and then apartments and
then eventually my mom
uh my mom now lives in a house in san
pedro and my dad lives in a house in
long beach did they remarry at all
no
no wow yeah
any chance of a rekindling uh between my
parents yeah
not and not
not nope no no not even for a second
male oh man yeah that's a lot to unpack
yeah that's that's pretty shocking to be
honest with you um did you go to college
uh i went for about a semester
this kid's a chameleon i'll tell you
that right now couldn't do it couldn't
do it well when i was younger i was like
uh i was a radio
personality
where i'm sorry i was so uncomfortable
am radio for the love of them no that
would be so i grew up my dad listened to
tom lycus growing up so that was like a
big
influence of my life you know like the
shock jock am radio okay
um but i like randomly called into 102.7
kiss fm ryan seacrest is the radio dj on
that what year are we talking this was
2003 to about 2006. so i called in i
mean you called it in 2003 in what grade
third grade third grade third grade yeah
i was like i was watching
i know i'm calling into the local radio
station for a set of sticks tickets dad
put down the binoculars for a minute
william what the [ __ ] holy [ __ ] and i
ended up just getting a job making prank
phone calls as a third grader as a third
grader
that's bananas
is that legal um it wasn't it wasn't at
first it was illegal it was child labor
and then they realized they had to pay
me so then i started getting paid but
that's why i went to college my parents
was it good money it was good money i
mean anything it's just like
that i'm the one who makes the prank
phone calls
were you getting were you actually
getting the money
um no it was being put into an account
that i couldn't touch until i was like
16. okay was it all there when you
turned six no my dad did use it for
patio
yeah
he
he really needed no furniture he needed
a good lounge to smoke his cigars and
seduce women
um but they put hats in there that's the
one of the most insane statements i've
heard in 200 episodes of the show patio
furniture give me a ballpark number of
what was in that account it was a good
amount i mean i have none of it left i
might have like two thousand dollars
left 20 grand 30 grand 40. i think i
think i had like a hundred thousand what
i was working every single week for
three years on the radio
what were you going to school yeah
because i would pre-record them i would
leave school early on like a tuesday or
wednesday i would pre-record four
episodes did kids know that you were
doing this did your teachers know oh
yeah did you get any of the money then
no
any cool presents or anything like hey
you can get the new bike or the whatever
no no cool presents but i would get to
go to like all the events with kiss fm
so that was cool i got to go to like the
concerts i got to introduce like gwen
stefani on stage at one of the you know
concerts that they as a third grader
yeah i think i would have heard about
this i know that should be national news
jihad yeah but then they let me touch it
when i was 16. so i'm like going to
coachella i'm buying all these ugly
outfits i buy a used car i was you know
modest about it but i bought like a 2016
jeep grand cherokee as soon as i turned
16. that's all right [ __ ]
yeah i mean all all my money or no no i
wasn't 2016. but uh what's it what's
your ticket to coachella run
it's
about i mean but then it was like what i
don't know maybe 400 bucks okay but then
i'm just buying a bunch of [ __ ] i don't
need of course yeah you went through
you're 16 with 100 jihads so half of the
money was in a college account so i
maybe had like 50 grand actually to
myself everything else as they say yeah
everything else
but it's like mom dad if your child is
calling into a radio station in third
grade she's not going to college yeah
what are we doing oh [ __ ] yeah so i
wasn't allowed to like spend that if i
did spend that for my own personal stuff
i was like taxed on it okay i got you
yeah so if i pull that money out i'm
still gonna be taxed on it that's all i
have left jesus and then why did you
stop doing that i'm doing what the radio
yeah so my name on the radio station was
lil alley and i think i just grew out of
it i wasn't too little anymore welcome
back it's little alley
my voice dropped
adolescent alley doesn't have the same
room
they threw me out of the talkies oh that
is wild man
what the [ __ ] yeah dude oh [ __ ] did have
you did you meet seacrest yeah a few
times he wasn't in the studio when i
went in yeah but yeah i mean i
definitely had a good like
if you said to seacrest today hey i'm
little annie would he go holy [ __ ] he
would remember yeah i mean yeah yeah
that was like it was a significantly
this guy's drinking too much ovaltine
over here yeah i got too much yeah i got
orphans on the brain wait what do you
mean he would know of course he would
know yeah yeah i mean it was like it was
very it was very popular when it was on
like locally it was very popular because
we started making bring phone calls and
we would make the prank phone calls in
california and then we had to start
doing them outside of california because
so many people would be like is this
that little girl
from the radio
he wouldn't recognize me but like for
sure if i mentioned that yeah holy [ __ ]
i know it's [ __ ] vodkas so you only
made it through a semester of college
only made it through a semester did we
say what college it was this really
terrible i didn't get i went to cal
state san marcos it's in north county
san diego it's literally for like the
most
sure you know i gotta get rid of the
word that i'm wanting to sounds like an
fx show yeah
it was so bad it was like people were
like they're like yeah i got in with a
point two five gpa
it wasn't a good time there's that
there's more than like one or two words
in the name of your school it's a bad
one no boy yeah harvard yale the name of
the school is just the city that the
school is located in the state yeah
california state san marcos yeah on
third street come see me
yeah we're d1 hacky sack yeah it's so
bad yeah so yeah i left and i want i
knew i i had done like one open mic
before going to college and i was like
this is what i want to do so the whole
time everyone's like what are you
majoring in and i'm like i'm actually
going to be a stand-up comedian damn and
they were like that's a fake job
have you seen my work on kiss fm yeah i
got 100 g says yeah it says different
photos
what was the high school mascot um my
high school mascot was the griffins
okay yeah not bad was the name of the
high school los salamidos high school
that's pretty good pretty good home of
the
home of the griffins
california
right a griffin yeah yeah what was it
griffin or it's a bird and a lion yeah
right yeah yeah what was high school
like high school
yeah we had a really good sports program
we had a really good like um theater and
arts program did you play any sports i
did dance all four years okay and i did
swim for one year
and i was really bad at swim so they put
me if there's swim meets if you ever
find yourself at a swim meet there's
always one lane off to the side that's a
fake lane it's like a participation lane
really and so they would put me in this
fake lane to compete because i wasn't
good at anything but then they realized
i was like kind of a ringer for one of
the laughs
and so then i finally got my shot i
imagine you're the kid that swim that's
swimming like sideways you're in the
other person's lane and [ __ ] they're
just
they're dropping those little like
torpedoes and i'm just finding them at
the bottom you're picking up rings and i
just want to note i don't know if
already picked up on this instead of
saying swimming she said swim we had a
good swim yeah that's bad it's my swim
team
not a good swim what is dance entail
dance you know you do well we would have
a show i think once or twice a year
through the school yeah and uh so we
would learn the different types of like
jazz hip-hop ballet you learn like the
basics of all of them and then you put
on you learn a routine
and then they don't only go you know
friday night or whatever yeah in the
auditorium yeah what was the grade
situation
um i was like a solid c average
solid state showing off i like it i like
it i got to be honest yeah i was too
yeah what was the sat score i have no
idea
if it cost a lot of money i might not
have even taken them like i'm not sure i
don't know i think they're free okay
then i took it yeah i don't remember
dude you were nothing but i was like no
it's insane what were your thoughts
about me before doing this like i said
yeah i guess you're sisters kind of yeah
you know what i mean just like basically
just like i don't know like you know as
two guys from the east coast like you
know a girl who grew up in california is
that stereotype sure i mean yeah yeah
surfing some not long shoremen [ __ ]
heritage i'll tell you that yeah your
mom's a long shoreman that's [ __ ]
insane wow she's got thick fingers
[Laughter]
all right let's get into some are you
garbage cues here uh where are you at
now you living in l.a still live in l.a
apartment roommates house apartment one
bedroom i used to be in like a four
bedroom
house
and it was it was like 800 a month for
rent it was a steal okay but then it got
too much cove it happened all my
roommates were on different pages so i
was like you know i'm going to be a big
girl i'm going to move out i'm going to
work on my own place
um so i've been living there uh it's not
a nice area no no
no it's chaotic
um i didn't realize the street i live on
is a main street and so the bus goes on
my street and so with that comes yeah if
you're if you're in a residential place
and there's a bus on youtube yeah a lot
of bus folk just walking around
[Laughter]
hippie athletic greens ag-1 a-g-1
had one yesterday yeah had one today
yesterday got me through one of the most
brutal workouts that my trainers put me
through yeah fantastic make you walk
through the drive through what are we
talking about
i was dead lifting buttface okay okay
you got me there i let one slip while i
was doing it yeah okay butts uh athletic
greens unbelievable yeah gut health
immunity
all natural i i literally can't say
enough about it i [ __ ] love it yeah
it's like a it's like a super duper
multi vitamin it's got everything you
need in it best part about it it's
lifestyle friendly whether you're doing
kale uh keto paleo vegan dairy free
gluten free they got you covered yeah
they do uh costs less than three dollars
a day you know everybody's taking some
sort of multivitamin and it's important
to choose high quality ingredients that
you know it's gonna work with your body
ag one's got you covered it takes out
all those questions this one that one
this one that one ag-1b listen i know
i'm not one to be talking about fitness
but i'm working on it i'm telling you
this stuff works it's fantastic it
tastes good you feel good when you drink
it uh it doesn't it it doesn't it's not
like drinking like whey protein sure or
any of that crap it's [ __ ] fantastic
i love it right now it's time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into cold and flu
seasons just one scoop and a cup of
water every day that's it no need for a
million different pills or supplements
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first purses
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com garbage again
that's athletic greens.com garbage to
take ownership of your health today do
it do it later
let's talk about ladder later let's talk
about this let's talk about you croaking
and leaving your family holding the bag
yeah which i believe is one of my
family's biggest concerns yeah you gotta
get out in front of that stuff
you gotta have a little something to
sprinkle the infield it's gotta be a
luncheon or something like that you
don't wanna be getting buried in a
refrigerator box out back by the pool
which is where i was heading before we
found ladder yes term life insurance you
know make sure you take care of your
family make sure you have things covered
those are the times we're living in no
doctors
no needles no paperwork when you apply
for three million or less in coverage
three mill you just need a few minutes
and a phone laptop to apply ladder smart
algorithms work in real time so you find
out if you're instantly approved if you
want to talk to a person like i always
say they got you but they don't work on
commissions no it's a licensed agent
they'll help you not upsell you yeah
they're not trying to they're not trying
to give you the hard sell on the
undercoat no hidden fees cancel at any
time get a full refund when you change
your mind in the first 30 days so go to
ladderlife.com garbage today to see if
you're instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life
garbage ladderlife.com garbage do it
yeah a lot of like police on my street
and i'm in one of the front units so i
just get to stare out the window and
like why are you on the first floor uh
yeah
yeah you're the first floor
that's bars on the windows no yeah there
should be sounds like there should be i
gotta be honest with you it's pulled up
on zillow it should be a gun up there
holy [ __ ] first floor yeah
yeah what's the whip like these days
what are you driving around i drive a uh
20
2018 kia sportage i got the basic one
myself
i love the kia it's all right i get [ __ ]
but it's already i'm a huge fan they're
also the only people that give me a car
that's how bad my credit was are you a
leasing or do you own um i'm financing
okay
you're buying yeah i'm buying it cool
yeah what are those payments like a
month you know what i did the lowest
payments over the longest period of time
um because i wanted to overdo the
payments and have the lowest like
interest on it sure right i don't know
how money works i know exactly what
you're talking about yeah so i did like
the longest plans like a four-year plan
my payments are supposed to be like 120
a month a month or something but i pay i
think the limit the most i can pay is
like 500
so i try and do that whenever i can
that's pretty smart yeah i just always
go for the longest time
that i have to pay it back well i was
worried i'm like if i have a bad year i
don't know what this everything could
fall apart like i don't know what's
gonna happen i'd rather have the lowest
in case i'm not doing too well
and then i'll sure i'll try and pay it
off as quickly chip away at it yeah that
makes sense what's uh what's the credit
score looking like i just checked i
think it's uh i think it's in
uh i just well i just got a credit card
for the first time this is big on this
show first credit card first credit card
all right credit limit
uh i don't know
what do they start you out i think it's
like maybe 2 000
respectable capital one uh chase
chase bank that's all right not bad not
bad i want to raise the limit on it
though i'm just too lazy to call
yeah it's you got to keep paying it yeah
it's tough right away i
just went through this a couple months
ago it's tough right away because now
i've established it okay you've
established yeah i've had it for a few
months i've been good i've been a good
girl i've been paying it i got confused
about the current balance or the
statement that still throws me through a
loop from time to time especially on the
corporate card but amex doesn't play
with the what's available what's it's
real it gets real air yeah so i just try
and like whichever one's the most money
i'm like that's probably what they want
from me yeah yeah you pay it all off at
the end of the month but there's a
statement if you yes but it's like the
billing period would be through the
first through the
first and then by the time that bill
comes out you might have spent more so
you currently owe
more than what's on the billing cycle if
that makes sense oh i don't like the
sound that happened yeah i have no idea
but i think i think i'm i i was telling
people you pay it off at the end of the
you pay the whole thing off yeah i pay
it all off or i do it like when i spend
if i just check my bank account and i
see that there's something in there i'm
like take it take my money same way um
but i think it's in like the low seven
hundreds because i'm still working
the high 600s
i just got knocked down a couple of
points though because we i just got
another credit card
got my i got my delta card do you get
knocked down if you get another credit
he gets back up again when you uh
i was thinking
when you
when they check your credit you lose
points i think that's a myth no
it just happened but they're running
hard to check
look at her i think that's a myth no
it's a hard check if they run a hard
credit check but a soft one like on my
on my banking app it has like your
credit journal yeah that doesn't matter
no but like if you go somewhere and say
like say you want to get another car and
like i want a car they'll pull a hard
credit check on you and that
knocks you like 15 points or something
like 10 points who's coming up with
these rules it's so fake
[ __ ] ripping us off it's [ __ ]
where was your vacation as a kid um we
didn't do too many
you don't say family vacations
wherever the cargo ship was heading me
my dad knocked over a bank one time
but like my dad we would do like road
trips with my sisters to vegas oh my god
okay this is a good story as kids
trips to vegas as kids i mean i told you
about my dad what do you think we were
doing in vegas oh my god probably a lot
of windows
to look into no balconies just
empty windows um
my dad took me and my sister was on a
trip to vegas and he was like my buddy
got me a great deal at this hotel
it's right by the strip house
i was pretty young i was oh
i was uh maybe six i have a weird
timeline i think i was just six-year-old
in vegas because your buddy got you a
good deal and he's selling it to the
kids it's right near the strip yeah and
we're
my sisters are seven and five years
older than me so six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve thirteen okay 11 and
13. yeah that seems about right maybe i
was a little bit older
still but yeah yeah so what did you feel
like you were 22 or something so we go
to vegas and the hotel we stay at is
this place called the new orleans
if you're staying at a hotel that's a
different place than vegas it's bad it's
bad it was so bad
my sister couldn't get a room at detroit
you know what i mean even at that young
age my sisters are like dad where have
you taken us it was so they have some
more wherewithal of like this is not
great yeah and me i'm like oh they have
one dollar hot dogs this is the best
and uh and so we stayed at this place we
go to the strip we go to the m m store
all that we go to the mgm there's this
little like uh you know the mgm's really
big there's weird there's like a car and
there's a line to just sit in this car
and so i'm like this is weird we all go
in line my sisters come with me inside
the car and they're like allie pretend
your own girl's gone wild i shouldn't
know what that is at the age of you know
six or seven
but i'm like okay so i lift up my top in
this car you know because it's just us
in the car i don't think anything of it
i'm just like girl's gone wild anything
for a laugh
and we get out of the car and i realize
there's the the reason people are
waiting in line is cause there's cameras
in the car to take pictures yeah just
like you know whatever it is like a
roller coaster yeah so we get out and
i'm mortified i realize that everyone
has just seen my flat six-year-old chest
jesus yeah so it's a fun trip where was
your dad
i gotta go see about a couple of things
you three look at the car all right he's
at the keynote table with his nose wide
open yeah
was he gambling while you were there no
i don't think we i remember moulin rouge
had just came out so whatever year that
was is however old i was we went to go
see moulin rouge and i the movie or the
play the movie the movie went to a movie
in vegas yeah yeah
and i started crying i hated the movie i
walked out um but yeah those were like
out of a movie at six
me two things
bonkers but yeah i gotta get back to the
radio station those were our family and
those were our family trips and then you
know maybe in like fifth grade my mom
took us to hawaii that's all right that
was a good trip she was she did end up i
think drinking on that trip or maybe it
was another hawaii trip
um so it kind of damaged
delta again why was she she was not
she was trying to get sober yeah i think
i think she had i think she had relapsed
or started drinking before the trips
when we got to hawaii we were all just
like pretending
we're like this is fun thanks for the
trip been on those trips
i've been there
yeah
[Laughter]
uh you were talking about a hernia
before any any injuries as a kid no
injuries out of hernia surgery i had a
bunion surgery in seventh grade just for
funsies preventative
a seven-year-old gets bunions no this
was in seventh grade oh seven so i was
maybe 12 12. i apologize wait that's
that's
what they correct your big toe yeah they
break it or something yeah they break it
they put a screw in it
at 12. yeah and then i had to get
another surgery to get the screw out
it was terrible this is nuts i know
and then did i have any other surgeries
i mean i got a tonsillectomy i had a
colonoscopy when when in ninth grade
what just to bond with my dad
there is good benny's i mean she did say
that i used there was there was no
reason no i mean i was having some
pretty bad bm's okay yeah and i was
always having like stomach problems but
i think it was just anxiety
you know sure 60 year old man yeah
i think that was about it though
what's up with the tattoo you got how
many tattoos do you have because i can
see about six i've spotted it i have
some bad small ones kind of so there's a
dollar sign on your palm yeah i dig this
one i clocked did you do that
yeah they just sell gun kits on amazon
so my friend
this was maybe last year
what whoa yeah
yeah so i did that
all my tattoos were really unoriginal
really trashy i just i used this one
here
barbed wire
and a flower so i did this comedy gig my
friend was like come do this show with
me it's a private event it's for this
super rich dude we're taking one of
those like you know musician tour buses
to utah and so we get there and it's so
bizarre the whole thing from start to
end is like i feel like i'm in some
weird modern sci-fi movie where like
we're gonna get murdered and whatever
um but they were doing tattoos in one of
the tour buses so i got one but the dude
whose uh show it was was this guy tony
shea the zappos founder
i just i just got a pair of zappos wait
hold on that's the guy that died or
killed himself like a few weeks after we
were there
at his house okay
what happened to him hold on what did he
do it wasn't good it wasn't good yeah he
went home to somewhere on the east coast
for thanksgiving and then uh died in a
fire
oh he did die in a fight did die in a
fire holy [ __ ] yeah the place where he
was staying burnt down oh that sucks
yeah yikes yikes so crazy
and i was with him like a few weeks
before
which is really not that weird but
it's trashy that you're making that
connection
and it was 27 days later you said it
like wednesday adams i know
i was with him
well no it makes more sense like if
like seeing the situation what happened
at the gig wait hold on there's more to
this he was like a he was super big
partier yeah i mean there was definitely
drugs involved there something was being
it was very dark or cooked yeah that's
why the house caught on fire yeah like
seeing the way that he was living with
all this money everyone around him was
just like signing off any idea he had
you could just tell that it like what
was happening so you make a certain
amount of money and you just have all
these people around you depend on you
it's got to be yeah it's got to go to
your head for sure yeah looking forward
to it going full crazy
i like it yeah so i i just get like all
these stupid last minute idea tattoos
and i can never come up with something
original or meaningful so i always just
like look up celebrity tattoos and just
pick and choose what i want which is
really embarrassing what's the total
number do you know um i think like 12
whoa but they're very like stupid sorry
what's celebrities have you stolen
okay so my finger tattoo the i and the
like equality sign is miley cyrus
respectable did you do that yourself uh
no this was my first tattoo i got when i
was in college
yeah it was like friday the 13th so they
do like 13 tattoos okay so i got these
as a package deal
and then i got bucks not too shabby yeah
and then i went to israel on birthright
right after college and i was going to
join the israeli army um
what yeah because i had no structure in
my life and i thought israel was really
beautiful your parents are jewish
my dad is jewish jewish longshoremen
yeah
they're out there you don't get that a
lot no no especially in california yeah
he's a unicorn on the on the docks
man so your dad's your mom's not jewish
my mom's not jewish um so i went to
israel on birthright i ended up staying
for like a month and i was like i want
to just like live here for two years
join the army and then when i'm done
i'll do comedy cause i'll be 21 i'll be
allowed to i didn't realize that you
could like do comedy in coffee shops i
was like i have to be 21 or else it
won't work and then when i got home my
mom was like crying and she was like
literally drop out of college do comedy
live with me don't join the israeli army
yeah so who'd you stay with when you
were over there how does that work um oh
he's fascinated in israel yeah well
first i stayed with a soldier who i
apparently made out with in a blackout
at a club and then he offered his place
to me for a week after the birthright
trip
so i stayed with him at his parents
house did you not have a place set up to
stay no because it was a last-minute
decision so i was on the birthright trip
for like 10 days how old are you at this
point i'm like 18. you're 18. how long
is the birthright trip ten days supposed
to be ten days so they give you ten days
to come over yeah and you before the
trip they're like do you wanna extend it
in advance and all you have to pay for
is like everything like we pay for the
flight home regardless of when it is who
does they do they do they pay for
everything for the 10 days for the 10
days they pay for everything so if you
extend the trip they just book your
flight home so they they put you up in
the hotel or whatever yeah you're not
staying in like nice places but like
they pay for it all and food and
everything um food you get breakfast and
dinner but if you want like anything
else
you pay it's not a bad deal it's not a
bad deal to israel that's pretty sweet
yeah ireland ain't doing that
yeah that's israel isn't it jewish
people it's like jewish people around
the world that i think fund it
yeah because they it's not it's not done
by israel specifically at all okay i
think it's done by jewish people all
over the world gotcha so everyone
everybody experience to go back
[Applause]
because the whole point is to like
indoctrinate you into doing what i did
joining
me
i had a lot of friends that did it yeah
and it worked i mean i wanted to stay so
by the end of the trip i was like i
don't want to go home yet that was my
first time living like actually away
from home and being like an independent
person
did you go and stay with the kids to the
guy's parents did you do that so
so
he texted me he's like
great meeting you last night i have no
idea who's texting me he was like if
you're staying like you can stay with me
his parents were out of town so the
first thing you do when you got there
was get hammered oh yeah at the first
opportunity
yeah yeah i got blacked out i have so
many crazy
this place is great i forgot everything
oh yeah
can't be hear about this coinbase that's
where i do all my crypto purchases you
do you're in swear to god i was a
customer before a guy an advertiser oh
i'm starting to dabble in this a little
bit oh all these bozos are making cash
off this cryptocurrency uh-huh i know
what they're doing
coinbase yeah simple easy they really
learn about it
selling buying cryptocurrency is easy
with coinbase yeah they i'm getting
involved they are getting in the market
they offer a trusted easy to use
platform to buy sell and spend
cryptocurrency the uh they support most
popular digital currencies on a market
and make uh make it make them accessible
to everybody they offer portfolio
management and protection learning
resources a mobile app that i got i got
the app i got the app oh i'm in hip meow
let it ride let's go whether you're
looking to divert divert to diversify
get started or just searching for a
better way to access access to crypto
markets start today with coinbase for a
limited time
uh our for a limited time new users can
get ten dollars in free bitcoin when you
sign up today at coinbase.com i'm
already rich get yourself a cup holy
wait your beak on this bitcoin what are
we doing let's go sign up uh uh sign up
at coinbase.com garbage for your 10 free
dollars in bitcoin this offer is limited
time only so be sure to sign up today
that's coinbase.com garbage now back to
the show yeah it was a nightmare looking
back on it i'm like that was so dark did
you have to go to services or anything
like that did you have to go to temple
or nothing no
playing edward 40 hands like i'm gonna
get the [ __ ] army dude
this place is
sick dude this is nothing like l.a
just doing the same [ __ ] there that i
was doing here they gave me a machine
gun the second i landed
this place is cool there's so much
hummus
forever the hummus that probably rocks
it does rock it's so good i can imagine
yes i stayed with him and then once his
parents got home he put me up in a
hostel like a true gentleman so i stayed
at this hostel
and i was there and then i stayed with a
uh with one of the soldiers because they
have like a few soldiers who join your
trip just for funsies they get to enjoy
the trip and so i stayed with her and
her family ended up being her parents
are like these israeli big personalities
like one of them's like the ellen
degeneres of israel and the dad is like
a
is like a
politician or something but after i left
every time i've after i left there were
like uh accusations that the dad was
like some sort of like perv or like
sexual misconduct and i'm like he didn't
make one move on
[ __ ] black blue girl
let's go so then i came home and didn't
join the army but started doing comedy
how close were you to joining the army i
was very close i was like filing out all
the paperwork paperwork that's that's
close that's as close that's not like an
idea you're kicking i told my dad i told
my grandma the jewish side of my family
was like yes
dude yeah
oh yeah yeah and then as soon as i told
my mom she was like crying smoking a
cigarette just like drop out of school
what kind of cigarettes is your mom
smoking um she used to smoke marlborough
reds but she's moved on to the cheaper
uh what are they called like usa's or
something something cheap something
smoke florida
palm balls yeah small girl paul mall
girl long shorts she's still smoking
yeah who likes the song
active smoker also for our next patreon
goal we should join the israeli army i'm
just saying
just [ __ ] saying
can we
make some calls
allie's got some connects over there she
used you as a tank
i like it all right bonkos man this one
is a [ __ ] it's twist and turns on
every ride i gotta say
um
before we get into the question really
get into the questions
is there anything else you think we need
to know or we should know
no
i highly doubt that
i'm sure i can't nothing i can think of
because to me all of this stuff is like
very normal
it's your story of course i was in isis
for a couple of weeks
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] whistle with your fingers no
but you wish you could i wish i could
this kid's garbage is so cool
um oh you know what i can't do either i
can't i can't spit i'm not a good like
hackaloogie spit
okay i feel like that's a good sign of
being garbage
good spit yeah yeah can you gleak do you
know what that is i'm not on command
okay but it'll surprise me out of
nowhere you know when you least expect
we all know what leaking is it's trashy
that she knows it and said not on
command
my friend's mom who i didn't realize
until i was older was like clearly uh
addicted to heroin she had a license
plate thing that said i'm in a better
place like eddie vetter
yeah big pearl jam head so she
she she was able to gleek on command and
i really looked up to her she was like a
second mom to me
this
is good lord uh
have you ever ridden a mechanical bull i
don't know where to go
i got one in my apartment
any relatives killed in a mudslide or a
stampede no
hmm any beekeepers in the family um
no oh i just found out uh my grandma
mentioned something to one of my sisters
that i might have a second family from
my dad being in israel staying at a
kibbutz so i might have like a really
old brother that i don't know about in
israel that's something we might want to
know what's a what's a kabutz a kibbutz
is like a it's almost like a commune
it's like a place where you live for
free but you help out with i thought it
was a sauna this whole time i'm not
gonna lie a kibbutz maybe they have
saunas no i think you're right it sounds
like a commune um
okay
when was that
i just found out about this a few weeks
ago and every time i've asked my dad
he's just kind of like ha ha i don't
know
who okay so i haven't really explored
i'm like also like what am i going to do
with this information go back to israel
join the army maybe
maybe um hmm have you ever had
thanksgiving dinner at a restaurant
one time we did thanksgiving on a cruise
my grandma took the whole family on a
cruise
thanksgiving yeah we went to mexico from
california
yeah from like long beach to mexico
in 2008. man i hooked up with a guy
named tanner he had a really raspy voice
because we were at the kids club because
on cruises they have like kids
nightclubs
what was this guy tanner hold on i
didn't know that i didn't get on a
cruise that makes sense like a dance
club yeah like uh you know yeah because
like you know your parents are out doing
whatever or whatever the kids go they're
saying
so there was a guy tanner and i my dad
he wasn't married to this woman but i
had a stepsister and a stepmom hold on a
second who did tanner or your dad no no
my dad so he he was with this woman and
her daughter was my age and i actually
set them up because they lived in the
same um like town homes as us and i was
selling cookie dough door-to-door in
elementary school you get cookie dough
you sell it i ended up stealing all the
money i forgot to pick up the cookie
dough so i had to go back and apologize
to everyone for taking their money and
not getting it we just asked you if
there was anything you wanted to add and
you pleased over there it's all coming
back
he got a baked good ponzi scheme going
in the townhouse community [ __ ] yeah i
think my dad pocketed all the money how
old are you at this point this was fifth
grade so 2005. so you're in fifth grade
this is when you went on the cruise
uh that was 2008
or no no no yeah it was 2008 so i was in
eighth grade
so 2005 you guys are living in a
townhouse yep you set your dad up with
this
woman as you referred to her as so i
became friends with her daughter because
i sold her daughter cookie dough and my
best friend the one whose mom was a big
eddie vetter fan they were in a heroin
addict yeah okay they were in hawaii so
my friend was gone from the town homes i
had no one to hang out no crew i meet
the cookie dough you know i meet the
girl selling cookie dough she's my age
and so we became friends and her mom was
single and my dad was single and i was
like well this seems like it makes sense
you guys should get together suddenly
ended up moving in with us and we became
step sisters
and no marriage no marriage they were
engaged but they never got married
and so we all went on a cruise 2008 and
me and her we went to the kids club and
we both found guys that we like so we
brought them back to our room
we all started making out with each
other yeah
what was the cookie dough thing was it
through school yeah through the school
you're like no cookie dough all right
yeah
get it to your head you raise money for
the school for like you know the program
yeah okay we would do it and we had like
those like magazines yeah yeah yeah yeah
not cookie though that's weird i know
do you know how to tie a lot of knots
no
do you have any weird talents
i uh when i was young
hey we got something who knows you got
something on the line here when i was
younger i was able to queef on commands
all right here we go
but i didn't know what it was at the
time until my sisters at family
gatherings would be like ali do that
thing you do laying on your back
huh i mean between that and the girls
going wild these two girls got your
[ __ ] number
yeah holy hey double joining what you
double jointed oh yeah my arms i like
they're double jointed you know they
don't stop where they're supposed to
my knees are locked
i'm not sure if she's from this planet i
know i don't know what's going on i've
never really been on my all my heels
this much
ever swam in a river
yeah yeah i went to kern river with the
neighbors um in long beach a big group
of people goes to kern river so my
neighbors who were
bad domestic abuse i had to call the
cops on them a few times who did
uh you did i called the cops on my
neighbors not when you were a kid but
when i was a kid
you caught you picked up the phone yeah
i'm a big karen if i see someone who
seems like they're drunk driving i call
the cops on them really yeah my mom my
mom has gotten three duis it's dangerous
i don't [ __ ] with it at all no i totally
i totally agree you know what i mean
you're like laying mom's business out
i know i just picture you in the back
seat like yeah this brawl's all over the
road
[ __ ] get her hurry up she's not
listening to me can't see aaron there's
a kid in the back
um so yeah they took me to kern river so
he would go like tubing and all of that
this is
before you you ratted them out
yeah this was before i ride at the
moment she didn't get the invite
afterwards so you're not bringing that
narc on the [ __ ] you're a kid
it's a lot of hanging out with the
neighbors oh one time child protective
services came to my dad's house and i
still to this day don't know if maybe my
mom called them just to spite him or if
someone maybe like felt like some vibe
was off
i still
don't know
just another thing i can't explain wait
so these neighbors they had they had
kids your age um they had a daughter who
was a little bit younger than me but we
got along and they had an older son who
was like really into [ __ ] like
shaving wood into knives um
oh dude where did you grow up
and they took you to on vacation with
them yeah it was like was there
three yeah without my dad
i was kind of like a latchkey kid my dad
trusted everyone sent me away did he
know these people pretty much yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was like safe and then
at some point there was a domestic
situation in the house yeah i remember
just being at home and hearing them like
screaming and it freaked me out parents
yeah it sounded bad and you called the
cops so i called the cops did they ever
come over and say somebody called the
cops on us no
no
man
god damn
this feels good
i feel really bad
do you i'm gonna go home and cry
um
you would let yourself into the house
when you get home from school yeah yeah
how would you get to school when you
were a kid um so
this ain't gonna be good no
i'm trying to think so
so i would get i'll wire a car
i would walk to school at one point i
lived close enough to school where i
could walk one time i i think i almost
got kidnapped
there was a huge van that came me and my
friend were walking home and this big
van came and they're like do you guys
need a ride home and we're like no and
they're like
our kids are in the back you can come
with us and i was like no thanks wow um
so i would walk and then sometimes my
stepmom before she was my stepmom would
give me rides and then when i was living
with my mom in high school at one point
i would take the bus to school like the
city bus the city bus
not the yellow cheese bus no city bus to
school is a tough look not in not where
i grew up i was normal yeah okay yeah
when you came in here you said i'm
interested
to see
if i'm garbage
those words came out of your mouth yeah
i didn't know where i'd land but now
that i'm like the forest gump of garbage
you've been she's like i almost i was
almost in the army i've been kidnapped
you've been just like around all of
these things that have happened there's
just photos of you in the background
with guy fieri yeah
aly i got to ask you this
what what is in your tooth right now oh
i have a tooth gem
i knew that's what it was and i was so
nervous to say anything
yeah i have a little tooth generally who
does that i'm a guy named sal sports
code tattoos oh yes or it's saul
saul or so let me see can i see it
so it's a tiny little gem they dig a
little hole in your tooth no they just
glue it
yeah just some elmer's do a little glue
and some blue light
but i had two i had this one and then i
had a gold dollar sign down below and
that one did fall off about two weeks
after i got it i was working at a wings
place i was a wing slinger a wing
slinger yeah i was the queen of wings
and i was i was eating a giant carrot
and it fell it fell off how long have
you had them about five years whoa yeah
that's been on there for five years i
think so
can i ask you how how old how old of a
person are you i think he could be 80. i
have no idea i'm 26. you're 26 years old
yeah
oh my god
lived a thousand lives
i feel like i'm talking all trash i feel
like i'm talking to the iceman over here
she's like yeah i've killed i want to
hate you right now
[Laughter]
all of this seems like he has like a
calmness to her i know so
unsettling and calming and warm at the
same time it's a lot it's not a real
diamond i would assume right no no no no
no that would be ridiculous i was like
40
that'd be ridiculous you get the cheap
dollar tattoo you know it was like a two
for one it was saint patty's you're
always with the deal
i love a deal
um
have you ever dated a guy who sold weed
i've never really like dated many people
seriously
um i don't think so i don't think i've
maybe i've hooked up with someone who
did but okay
but i've never dated any any
professional skateboarders
um uh
no
anybody in a band
uh no i went on a date with a guy in a
band okay what a successful band
uh fairly not not
fairly successful i've talked about it
on my podcast it's this dude uh sam he's
in this band called white reaper
oh i've heard a white reaper yeah
they're great yeah so we went on two
dates he plays i think the base
cool cool dude
cool we didn't catch her or anything
didn't click but uh great guy great
great musician okay okay
um
do you enjoy any of the following smells
asphalt
fresh asphalt
gasoline horses magic marker all of it
all of it yeah she does all of it
i just went to a rodeo
and it where you strike me as a smeller
are you a smeller i'm a smeller yeah
yeah i said i pick my butt and i smell
it you know i'm a smeller yeah in there
yeah
[Laughter]
i was literally not prepared for this
episode i was gonna ask her she ever
owned a chia pet i pick my butt no i
pick my butt and i smell it
do you guys not do that one hundred
percent i know we've talked about it
recently i've done it so much that i
don't need to know i don't need to do it
anymore i know what's there yeah you
know what i mean i'm not there's no
uncharted territory it's not that i'm
doing it to smell it it's just like if
my butt's itchy i'm gonna itch it but it
kind of it comes yeah it comes up it's
like a pavlovian it is like you won't go
right over you're like let me just make
sure it's still there yeah yeah you know
of course
um
have you ever crashed someone else's car
someone no i've i've crashed my car
twice what so oh this okay so when i um
so when i i sold my jeep grand cherokee
because i was driving up to la from long
beach every night to do open mics and
the gas was terrible you know it's like
sixty dollars every week at the time to
fill it up and so i bought um i bought i
forget what the car was but i bought it
brand new in cash with my radio money
four days later
four days later radio which is an insane
statement yeah i know four days later i
crash it trying to get dick at a hostel
where these two australian guys were
staying i make this illegal u-turn i get
t-boned by a woman named elmo
and uh
her name was like something elmo or elmo
something it was a really weird name
and
so i crashed my car i total it because
it's a brand new car
they gave me all the money that it was
worth which was everything so i so i got
the same car but this time in the color
white because i was like if it's a white
car everyone will see it no one will
crash into me 28 days after i get this
brand new car i crash it in a blackout
on the freeway
and so then it's totaled again and you
drunk blackout or in a drunk blackout no
in a drunk what happened to you calling
the cops on duis and stuff someone
should have called on me
that's their fault
was around yeah
yeah i wish my brain wasn't asleep when
you call the cops hold on back up to the
australian guys real quick yeah did you
like you made it seem like they were on
the side of the road and you like well i
found a great parking spot right in
front of the hospital oh okay so i was
like oh i gotta take that spot right
away where did you meet these guys at
the comedy store
you were performing i think i was
probably hanging out maybe i was
performing these are just two australian
guys two australian guys which one were
you gonna hook up with either
flip it flip a coin you know okay i
think they also had cocaine so i was
like they're just cool guys uh-huh and a
hostel yeah on holiday yeah
they were staying at the banana bungalow
so i make this illegal that's a perfect
name for two guys from australia sling
and dick
banana bungalow also not the first time
i've been to that hostel to hook up i
hooked up with a um with a white rapper
from atlanta at this hostel we got a
name on him i don't remember his name it
was like ghost or something like that
yeah
she likes the transients
i could date a guy could they do basis
from white white reaper but i'm gonna go
with ghost from atlanta
who's staying at the banana boat yeah
man i've never i've never been in a
hostel
uh
that's what you'd expect
why wouldn't you take them back to your
place um
good question i don't know
i don't know were you living in long
beach at the time were you in l.a i
think at this point i'd moved to l.a
oh that's probably why i was living at
home yeah still living at home it was
too far i'm sure your dad wouldn't want
to watch
you guys were you posing that night uh
no no i was sober but dick hungry you
know dick drunk sure
um
yeah so then i crashed my car again 28
days later in a blackout ended up
getting away with it i never got okay
yeah
yeah until now until now yeah
and then with the money so they gave me
the money back once again so i had maybe
like fifteen thousand
and this was i was running low on funds
at this point already
so i spent so the 15 000 i ended up
going to
london i was gonna move there
because i was like 19 i wanted to do
comedy and i was like i'm gonna go to
london
because i can drink there legally wait
all this is going on
like the australian guys you're 18 19 at
this point yeah
yeah and then i go to london and i
didn't realize i don't know how like
she's told
literally 70 years of stories if you
were making all this stuff up
that would be unbelievable no this is
all real i was i was gonna go to london
i was gonna live there and my friend
told me like about three weeks before
the trip like you have to have a green
card like a visa yeah and i was like no
i'll get one when i'm out there i'll
find a job at a bar or a coffee shop
she's like that's not how it works so it
ended up being like a three week trip
london paris berlin and i was like
blacked out for the whole time and i
spent all of my money did you go by
yourself i went by myself yeah man yeah
it's pretty pretty solid yeah
torn around europe by yourself she
started working when she was eight what
do you expect
you didn't want to bring a friend with
you or anything um no
no i wanted to like reinvent myself
and then when i came back from this trip
i ended up getting sober oh you're sober
now yeah so i've been sober for like six
years now oh congratulations no i don't
smoke weed anything no
totally straight totally straight la's
sober i've heard that term before yeah
no i can't do la sober okay
good that's awesome it's awesome
i mean based on these stories it was
yeah no i've
you know for sure
i want to call soldiers and services on
your parents now
retroactively
you guys really screwed the pooch on
this broad yeah
oh god i don't i mean
i
you know
what about now what about now what's
going on now um
you got your own place i got my own
place i've i'm in a good relationship
i've been with my boyfriend for like a
year and some change um my parents are
great i love them i'm working
um
yeah i feel like it's kind of a 180.
that's great yeah
yeah i mean i'm good i don't need to ask
i have all the information i need for
sure do you think your parents were
involved with stealing the amazon
packages from those trains
[Laughter]
no or else i would have like you know i
would i would have cops on them
i'm a
no one's safe
no my god ladies and gentlemen
ally the cops wow everybody the
multi-faceted
that's freaking we barely scratched the
surface too
do you think there's anything else no i
think you need to tell us i think that i
think that does cover it
[Laughter]
she's so calm when she delivers these
stories very serial killer yeah very you
think so 100
and your eyes lit up when i called you a
serial killer which makes me think it
even more
i just like that i you know appear one
way and then
you know the more you dig the more you
find out
even the way you did dig was a little
creepy
oh my god
when you dig you have to use your back
it's really important
you don't want to make too shallow of a
hole
[Laughter]
especially if the ground's hard you got
to really get in there you don't want
anybody finding the body and the climate
you know the mud could be either like
really dense or
good lord
what a wild one what do you think
what
[ __ ] trash i mean she turned it
around the past couple of months i'll
give her that i'll class in my book as
far as i'm concerned
i mean her mom is a longshoreman that's
insane that's unbelievable that's so
cool yeah there's a lot of people in my
family who are along sherman wait what
do you mean more yeah nana
a lot of people on my mom's side of the
family because my mom i was born in san
pedro
my mom's family grew up in san pedro and
that's where the port is so a lot of
people there are long shorelines yeah
all right so there's actually yeah oh
man yeah 100
i think also a lot of the times when i
present the stories i feel like the
backstory of it all makes it a little
bit more like balanced but when i say it
it comes off very like insane sure yeah
but to me i'm like there's there's like
reasons it makes sense in your head but
we're only hearing this one yeah totally
you know yeah yeah for sure of course
i don't know about that
i think any way you slice it ladies and
gentlemen once again aly makovsky uh
buddy what do you have coming up what
the folks out there to know um if you
want to see me on the road you can go to
aliminkowski.com
shows um my podcast is called resting
[ __ ] and uh
that's all you need to know highly
recommend super funny this was
unbelievable kippy what do you got for
him uh check us out we're on the road
all over the place adding more dates
soon so let's go get those tickets on
the middle class famous tour baby kevin
ryan comedy on all social media and
patreon.com gang we love you we'll see
you next week peace